Jim Ditka goryeo knows what he wants an
old-fashioned girl brought up in a
strict family where maybe Papa was in
charge says she's used to a man being in
charge I prefer to be captain of my ship
he's paid two and a half thousand pounds
to attend a so-called romance tour in
Ukraine is aim to find a wife he's
preparing for a social where each
Western man will be outnumbered by at
least seven women Galina is equally
clear about her intentions
she says she's waiting for her destiny
which is her man very thing to move
along with you tired of local men who
only want a fling she says she's ready
for a family it's these traditional
values and looks that make Russian and
Ukrainian women the most popular and
sought after in the mail-order bride
market the social is billed as buzzing
the age gap between the male and female
participants striking flirting is aided
by translators I look like a celebrity
Oh Roger doesn't take long to cut to the
chase
is she gonna marry me income the United
States
the conversation fails there are more
obvious ways to attract attention
the people who run the company say this
is just dating others say it's one step
away from trafficking if the condition
is worth that war believe me that'll
usually power this phenomena is a
variation of prostitution and human
trait because the same logic on it even
if they claim the woman has chosen this
it is still the trail of a human beings
broadly speaking the idea of women's
independence just hasn't penetrated
Ukrainian and Russian society yet in
Moscow the rise of the super-rich
has been huge but there's still a
lingering attitude that Western men are
the key to wealth and happiness in
Russia 25,000 women every year
sign up to marriage agencies this Moscow
agency is unabashed
about putting young women with older
wealthy Western men option basically
similar though if the girl is young and
pretty why shouldn't she sell herself
and make a profit if she's beautiful why
should she be poor back in Odessa as if
in need of further titillation the men
are treated to a bikini contest many of
them say they're tired of aggressive
feminist Western women but for a lot of
these women the West equals freedom to
ideals that down the line can become
very much at odds